it's funny isn't it i think that one of  the most advanced forms of technology  these days rechargeable state-of-the-art  batteries begin their life with that  glugging noise  over there as that concentrated brine  solution is pumped through from that  pond  over to this one look you can see it  coming out there now that  is about 25  lithium chloride that is going to go  into your smartphone battery or your  electric car  it's a special place this place though  oh definitely yes  these are the special conditions for the  salary to form  these mountains  falls volcanic rocks  water and perfect addition for  evaporation so arid places